at the network known for lies they keep
dropping like flies it looks like cnn's
integrity broke down starting from the
top down and apparently those comically
giant swabs
couldn't protect these horny
slobs cnn president jeff zucker resigned
today affected immediately it's the
first time he's been effective in a
while
and lo and behold zuck has his former
star anchor chris cuomo to thank
said zucker in a memorandum as part of
the investigation into chris cuomo's
tenure at cnn i was asked about a
consensual relationship with my closest
colleague someone i have worked with for
more than 20 years i acknowledge the
relationship evolved in recent years i
was required to disclose it when it
began but i didn't i was wrong as a
result i'm resigning today that sounds
fishy
but i gotta say chris cuomo has damaged
more reputations than jeffrey epstein's
flight logs so for duck sucker it all
comes to crashing down because of
consensual sex with an adult colleague
well they call that at cnn trying
something new
it is a welcome departure from most of
the lurid disgusting stuff happening
over there
why are they so damn horny at that
network sounds like their dress code is
pants optional but what a mess for cnn
zucker steps down while his sinking ship
of a network peddles non-stop hoaxes to
a disappearing audience not to mention
they eat crickets over there
i'd say good good riddance zucker and
don't let the door hit you on the way
out but then cnn will blame the door for
a hate crime
in fact their tributes to him have
already started
uh thank you all for coming and welcome
to the cnn chapel i didn't know this was
in here either uh for those of you
joining us via zoom uh please oh tuban
your camera is on
where was i uh as you know we recently
had to say goodbye to jeff zucker and i
thought this would be a good opportunity
for those who knew him best to say
something nice so i'll go ahead and get
things started um when you think about
it the number of pedophile producers he
hired was actually pretty small
i think that jeff zucker was treated
unfairly i mean i read chris cuomo's
deposition thank you thank you okay
thank you so much that's enough
uh anyone else
yeah i just gotta say i mean facebook
has been great for the world so uh you
know we should be selling this jeff
zucker
i those for mark zuckerberg i'm an idiot
is there anyone here who has anything
nice to say there's 2 000 people in this
room jim acosta you have no questions
okay that's enough that's enough
uh also um per brian stelter's request
there is catering in the lobby
we had to we had to end on that note i
cat okay
i wanted to enjoy this story so much and
then it's i hear it's a it's about a
consensual relationship and not about
their
ratings it should be about how bad the
network is and they're doing i do not
buy this story i know i want to know
what really happened yes because he
resigned which means he was worried
about getting fired for something
actually bad like i get that this is
like wrong like a hr technicality but
like you know like maybe i'm like a
misogynistic pervert but you know he was
like doing sex with someone who was
wanting to do sex with him too
so i mean that's not there's something
else there something else there's
something smelly and stinky and gross
katie and i want to know everything
about it i want this story to last for
five months
look cnn and the relationship with the
cuomo's was like dousing the building
with gasoline and chris cuomo is holding
the match on the way out and he's about
to throw it in there because when they
fired him after everything that they did
to protect the cuomo brothers getting
rid of him putting it all on chris cuomo
this is cuomo's revenge they mess with
the gangster brothers and they're
getting it back right now this is not
the end of it you can't tell me that
this is about sex like with tube in
there still a richard quest situation a
couple of years ago
uh the pedophile producers that are now
under investigation and criminal
investigation there's way more to this
about yes that we're going to find out
hopefully cuomo's revenge
medical problem
did you get in tuscany
i don't know where i was going jamie i
don't either but let's go together
right let me ask you a question i'll
follow you anywhere
will you
will you follow me with a coherent leave
yeah
see this is what's happening and you
know what
i'm starting to like chris cuomo again
what's going on tell us what do you have
any cnn jokes i immediately well i i
immediately well i think when we all
read this i said like i'm not even
kidding at first i go do i not know what
consensual means
have you ever done that like i go have i
been like miss saying this the entire
time
it just didn't make any sense
i can't wait to hear more information
about this but i will say one thing i i
have a goal that to someday
be able to resign
because
that means like you're you have a good
job
you know what i mean like you don't
tender your resignation at arby's no you
don't you quit you fill your bag with
potato cakes and you get out of there
yes but i can't i can't wait to hear
more and then because the tubing not to
state the obvious but it's like his the
tubing thing chances are that was
consensual with himself yeah okay and um
and he's still at cnn and by the way you
brought up richard quest a great story
that people forgot about in central park
he was wearing
a a a collar around his neck that was
attached to another appendage he had
meth in his pocket and they took him
back that's why i know that i'll always
have a chance
no i'm like he was he wasn't hurting
anybody by himself it was consensual it
was insane
all right tyrus we were talking what
what's going on okay um well first of
all uh
you got to say consensual different he
was having consensual sex
with a woman
[Laughter]
okay all right
here's what really happened yes i don't
know this to be true
bill maher but i feel like it's true
yeah
his
love interest
worked for somebody yes who was it that
she worked for andrew cuomo quick pro
quo greg yes and he got into trouble did
he not and he had an insider who knew
the owner or the boss of the news
company
and i know his brother got busted for
interfering and helping but
yeah he was getting help from perhaps
somebody a little higher on the food
chain
and then they promised cuomo that he
wouldn't have to fall on his sword but
then they thought that since they called
him fredo he would do the fredo thing ah
very good you know and you know the but
he they should he wasn't the uncle with
the olive oil cut his wrists in the
bathtub yes fredo made a deal and now
fredo's telling on everybody yeah and uh
he's and if you want to bet a dollar
that by i don't know friday
there'll be something really bad that
comes out and there'll be a lot more
resignations
you know saying i'm leaving because i
cheated on my wife 14 years ago
yeah statute of limitations ran out bro
so what else she got and i'm sure cuomo
is laughing somewhere
going oh yeah wait till this so yeah
it's not like safe be do you think he
felt safe in the relationship because
allison was like don't worry no one's
watching
and when they got busted she was like no
not our relationship cnn no one's
watching exactly
all right well
i feel great
up next it appears an interview was a
joke
to make the nfl seem woke hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else